- [Gary] This is the first
time I've been here.
- I'm gonna be so inspired here.
- [Gary] You think?
I'm inspired regardless.
I can be inspired,
I can be inspired if
they put me in like a jail cell.
I live in an apartment now.
It's crazy to me that
I don't need a big house.
You grow up, you
don't need a lot of room.
With less room
you'll need less stuff.
I don't need five
70 inch TV screens.
I don't need a watch,
I don't even wear a watch.
I don't need a cool watch.
I don't need a boat.
I need the game.
I know myself.
And that's how I act.
Other people want things
that they don't really need.
Things that aren't
gonna make them happy.
They're not fulfilled inside.
I'm always trying to challenge
people to get to their true self
because once you
understand yourself,
self-awareness is maybe you
should be number two,
number five, number seven,
number twelve, maybe should be
an accountant not an entrepreneur
because you could become the CFO
of an entrepreneur's
company and make $1 billion.
To me self-awareness is what are
you good at, what do you like,
what puts you in a
position to be successful,
then do that.
(somber music)